[Musique]
bien ce matin en nous y étions tous très
contents d'être rassemblés aso donc pour
la cérémonie de remise des diplômes de
master de l'université paris saclay pour
la school sur sociale cette school a
souhaité se réunir d'abord pour pour
célébrer ces premiers diplômés donc
c'est il s'agit de la première promotion
donc des masters de l'université paris-x
s'appelait c'est un travail de longue
haleine puisque on l'a préparé il ya
maintenant plus de quatre ans donc
c'était avant tout donc un travail
collaboratif entre les équipes de
recherche travaillant dans le domaine
des sciences sociales sur à l'université
paris-x sacré les équipes ayant décidé
donc de mettre la force de leur
laboratoire pour la création de
nouvelles structures de formation de
master donc pour la school sciences
sociales dans les domaines de la
sociologie des sciences sociales de
l'économie mais aussi donc de la banque
de la finance
l'université paris saclay dont au niveau
de la de la formation c'est une
expérience qui est unique en france
puisque nous avons été accrédités pour
49 mentions de masse tard d'autres
connus se saisissent aussi de cette
opportunité de faire travailler les
communautés scientifiques ensemble
autour des objets de formation par la
recherche que ce soit le master et le
doctorat donc pour l'université paris
saclay donc 100% gris doctorants sont
rassemblés donc sous la bannière paris
saclay au fur et à mesure des années le
nombre de mentions augmente nous avons
commencé à 44 mentions oussama 46
mentions donc cette année ce qui rend
compte à peu près neuf mille cinq cents
étudiants
donc il y avait aujourd'hui près de deux
cents 200 diplômés présents avec leurs
familles beaucoup de gens en tout cas
donc
pour représenter donc l'équipe
enseignante aussi des personnels support
donc les sécrétariat pédagogique les
services de scolarité et c'est aussi ça
donc que l'université paris-x sacré
c'est cette mise en réseau des
différentes catégories de personnel donc
qu'on a souhaité rassembler aujourd'hui
autour autour des cérémonies
[Musique]